so clevenger is on top of the mound he
is all warmed up and ready to go
one and one a 491 era with the padres
and here comes brandon bauer brian
voters third base coach picks up his
runner at second there dickerson
clevenger deals hung a breaking ball
popped into left field fernando going
out
coming in his profile profile makes the
call he makes the catch and straightaway
shadow left field
he hung one and got away with it so far
good day for clevenger huh sure
he got the single that runner got the
second on the fielder's choice and
mike left him there the giant starting
pitcher in game one
is the right-hander johnny cueto 2-0
with a 4-5-6
earned run average here's manny machado
two
lifetime home runs against cueto jacks
outfield bunched up towards center the
infield swung over toward the third base
side against him cueto again with a
shimmy and a shake delivers
and a broken bat flare into shallow left
in comes dickerson
for the catch inning over may have
broken his bat on that one
three up three down we go to the second
longoria smoke
and crawford coming up and it's nothing
to nothing two down on the second four
in a row retired by clevenger
and here's brandon crawford oh one
ground ball clevenger with a beautiful
grab you weren't even looking at the
plate
it just squatted down balding glove he's
a good feeler man he showed it again
there
and the throw over that is all for
brandon crawford now three for his last
19
crab by mike clevenger he goes one two
three
two down here in the second second and
third and a chance here for greg garcia
to do some damage and
get the padres on the board here in the
second frame
to left field for garcia dickerson
coming in that's in for a base in
from third nola will score here comes
cronenworth he'll score
and it is a two-run single for greg
garcia and the padres take a two-nothing
lead in the second inning
two run single with two down for garcia
that's a big hit
two down garcia first hand here's jerks
and profar
now the pinch swing and a
squibber caught at third by longoria
lunging to his left about
ankle high so far
didn't seem to hit it all that hard
[Music]
but it never hit the ground either and
longoria had time to move to his left to
catch it
but two runs for the pods we head to the
third inning dubon
trump and jastremski do up the giants
are trailing two nothing
so two down and will myers who has two
of the seven grand slams is coming up
here's the first pitch to will hard hit
on the ground and through the left side
for a base hit grisham comes in to score
manny's coming behind him dickerson's
throw to the plate is not in time and
out in front of the dish
a two-run single for will myers and the
padres come through with a two-out rally
here in the third inning double their
lead
four to nothing san diego and now jake
cronenworth who
doubled and scored his first time is at
the dish to face cueto the second time
the 1-1 pitch is hit high in the air to
center field dubon
going back on it squaring up short of
the warning track he'll make the catch
for out number three giants still have a
whole nother game to play today
so cueto gets through three but two more
runs for the padres
here's solano entered play with the
third highest batting average in the
national league today
well now nobody avoids the 3-2 from
clevenger in a broken background or up
the middle clevenger on his knees stabs
it has it throws to first two away
a second time this afternoon mike
clevenger has made a really nice
defensive play he got crawford in the
second
he gets solano in the fourth one now one
on and trent grisham coming up
the pitch that one is hit hard on one
hop
speared by solano to his left he'll spin
around and go to second for one crawford
back to first
double play well nicely turned grisham
is staring out there in disbelief he
thought that was a hit all the way
instead it's two outs so beautifully
done by solano
crawford and belt double play ends the
inning we go to the fifth still time for
the giants are down four nothing
to the padres mauricio dobano for one he
flew out
to trent christian center field his
first time
one ball no strikes to dobond here's the
pitch from clevenger out in front taps
it to third manny charging in near the
bag
off balance throw got him oh boy not an
easy play but he sure makes it look like
it is
two out double by crawford he's left at
third middle of the fifth inning at
petco padres lead the giants four to
nothing
so here comes struck out looking leading
off the game and then
walked in the third the only walk
allowed by clevenger
this is caught a third by machado up
into the air goes manny machado to reel
that in
[Music]
he's tired of watching tatis do all that
stuff he's going to do it himself
because he can he's manny machado fires
his flight out to right center and then
with the bases loaded and two down in
the third inning and got a big hit
a single to left it knocked in two runs
and suddenly a two nothing lead was four
nothing
[Applause]
longoria on the bare hand and it's not
in time
it's one they'll look at brilliant play
by longoria who was playing deep for a
powerful right-handed hitter
he came rushing in bare-handed the ball
and made the across the body throw
and the jacks are going to appeal the
play and there's the call from new york
it didn't take long
and that will bring up greg garcia who
drove in a pair in the second inning
four nothing padres cueto looking at
second base
dancing around there's nola comes back
with the ground ball slowly
second base grab and went right through
crawford's glove into left field
here comes the runner here comes nola
here comes the padres
by five to nothing on an error by the
san francisco giants
before the base hit to right is last
time up a one for two day
lined into right field a base hit over
the head of belt and from third base
connerworth will score the sixth padres
run at six and i think san diego
jerks and profile with his second hand
drives in another run
so now longoria who is 0 for two with
two strikeouts against clevenger
on the ground left side deep short tatis
got a long throw no problem
padres win